Bà về tâm sự lọc một lớp để dựa hoa ở trường thường học nghe đức thành phố Vinh, hưu trường nó gì?
Lên quan đến vụ chiếm bà về tâm sự lọc một lớp để dựa dựa hoa ở trường thường học nghe đức thành phố Vinh.
Bà lớp thì thử hoa, hưu trường dành thích sẽ nhảm bà tân mối xai của trường vô hành thiệt.
Bây giờ, nha trường quyết định dựa tàn vụ điều hoa của các phòng hàng chính và mối sáo tiếp điều hoa,
của tảm lức học ở giải phòng học cố đã sống cấp sản giải nhảm mối xai sau không lủ tài.
Nên trường này cũng phải là một đường định bà pha dân cho điều hoa tử lấp học,
sau cuộc đィện cho cộng trường tức dây điều hoa cố không nhiều điều hoa mối,
kéo châu Âm đồng bị hư, nha trường phê bảo dưỡng, càng theo dây điện của thế,
số tiên hơn bà về tâm trường lọc là tổng givy để dưới 2 điều hoa một lấp,
tương đơn hơn 1 phê trị trộ lọc một điều hoa.
Bằng giá trị phê dưỡ lệ sông nhà thử đưa ra, và cuộc học này mới bà táng mời, nha trường đã thông bà với phụ Vinh,
trong đó, nha trường vội trợ bội lắm một phê bà trợ đồng.
Phụ Vinh chỉ phải đón hơn 2 phy năm trợ đồng còn lại,
hư trường trường trường tiêu học y đức thư dân,
kéo sốt là mối chỉ hội ý vấn đề này với tăng đại dễm chá mẹ học sinh của trường.
Mà không chào bởi vì tất cả các lốc phía thời gian cấp dưỡng,
về tượng này bà hoang vương thảo, trường phong giá dụ bó đá tạo thành phố Vinh cho biết,
phong đã chỉ đạo bàn giả việc trường tiêu học y đức,
kích tục sẽ tích cho phụ Vinh hiểu giá phê gí phí dựa giữa hoa từ phong học của sang phong học mới,
theo bà phương thảo, đây là tiên vấn đặc tại trường giá dụng, nhanh ra trường từ kỹ trước sửa bà cạo sau là xa kỹ trình.